there is a terrific Bill coming out of
Oklahoma a bill that would ban
pornography which is something that
pretty much everyone wants other than
the perverts and the weirdos everyone
wants this and everyone has wanted to
ban or severely curtail pornography
forever it's not a republican thing it's
not a Democrat thing forever obscenity
pornography was banned in America for
most of our history in most places and
then even in the '90s when the internet
came out and and lawmakers had to
Grapple with this new technology problem
both parties came together to regulate
and severely limit pornography they did
it through two pieces of legislation the
communications decency act which is
where you get the section 230 that
protects big tech companies in some ways
from uh oversight and in the child
online protection act both passed by
Republicans Democrats signed by Bill
Clinton it was just some Libs on the
court who shot it down and pretended
that there was a First Amendment right
to weird hardcore porn